le français 6e champions se trouve une
fois de plus pour une petite compilation
de jours commence tout de suite avec m
ça c'était honteux mlg flapi beurre qui
vient de rentrer dans le top 10 des jeux
de game jol tsai la souris à ça qu'on
veut ça fait une éternité
c'est ce qui se passe les situations
scabreuses comme ça ça fait mal aux
oreilles se dit qu'on allait arrêter
l'explication tout de suite
56 m j'ai même fait un discours aussi
bien sur le keeper dans l espagne ou
parce qu'ils nous ont aidés pas du tout
pas du tout j'adore la musique épique
qui rend le climat
je sais pas si on passe notre listing
dogues
ok on est pas mal on est bien on est
bien vraiment au nom adam on peut faire
beaucoup mieux que ça c'est sûr et
certain alors on va être corrompus tard
oh [ __ ] oh non ok ok oh non c'est un
complot des illuminati sont responsables
de sa dette est une dette non non et ben
franchement ce flambeur des bien mieux
au software et arkane aller non non mais
quelle arnaque
donc je veux pas qu à moyen et à les
regarder
j'étais janvier agissez en live et où
c'est pas du tout les bois après
enregistrés nous la peace man à la la
fecq avis un peu à peu du land rien on
est là on passe en touristique dingue
mais on n'avance pas vite
au moins là alors a pu le regarder mais
regardez comment c'est fou quoi soop
togolais puis d'un coup hop un tuyau bas
en haut mais regardez c'est roma
fair-play quoi ce job d'été c'est simple
allons il va y avoir du mal à 4 quand on
en passe te veux pas qu'il doit pas se
brûler trop fourbe te mets à réal et non
l'état 4 10 ans et pourquoi j'ai fait ça
l'objectif sur un jeu auquel personne de
jours
oh non ouais ça va quoi je te smac avec
malou cigarette n'est pas une cigarette
[Musique]
à la toux qui fait qu'on doit quitter
chez ea les jeux suivants bordel on est
sur where is my dans la mer voilà c'est
pour se détendre un petit coup puisque
cela se faisait un peu fâché cela pue et
on peut lire tous deux nous a très
énervé voilà c'est un jeu dont le but
est extrêmement mekhissi fausse marteau
[ __ ] ok voilà le but extrêmement
simple c'est tout casser voilà quand on
donne nous a énervés
bah en fait tout mon gars et c'est le
but du jeu je pense qu'on va jouer à la
passe et au jeu suivant à l'estec tu
peux tout péter même les marches
ah non je savais bien les marches ça se
cache jamais vous avez démarche cassé
oui bah ma théorie est nul alors
regarder un placebo cela n'a aucun
intérêt mais c'est extrêmement beau ça
fait c'est pour le plaisir de casser
nous cassent la milca sert plus qu'à ce
de trucs plus mon jeu smara messac
excellent aussi combien mais par exemple
la semaine c'est le cas c'est pour
joindre le salon à la cuisine
et là je me retrouve dans les chiottes
sais pas trop pourquoi on me regardait
plus casse de trucs plus arabe
regardez je suis à quatorze images
seconde bonjour je rame pourriez vous me
donner des fps des images par seconde
éventuellement j'essaie vraiment bien à
la bientôt j'ai pas le temps voilà je
m'en vais au travail pour mon petit
tracteur juste là et je m'en vais hop
et voilà je répare mais mon tracteur
sans aucun problème ah ah on a un crash
jackson bon jeu suivant ça suffit on est
maintenant sur tablette un jeu vous
m'avez beaucoup conseillé quoi c'est
waou d'accord ça avance et je suppose
qu'il faut que j'avance plus vite que ça
n'avance voilà ce que ces explications
sont assez claires pour vous c'est
génial c'est il est beau le jeu aucune
attention aux voitures et bout les idées
on me l'a envoyé par exemple j'ai passé
un champ faut que j'avance mais voilà le
camion cadeau gratuit
qu'est-ce que j'ai eus ouais on a eu
l'appui nous inviterons bien sans
déconner oh c'est quoi ça ok c'est rond
de temps mais c'est carrément ghetto
cette route quoi est les points d'eau
avec des bûches qui passe et qui
flottent fin à ce moment là il ya un
tsunami a pu de voitures quoi attention
à faire un run
non alors hop hop
olala mais c'est génial je comprends
pour mettre tout ce que ces jupes c'est
la bête addictif mais un truc de dingue
c'est un freud en bd coup je vous parle
le temps passe vite
ça il a fait un crime oh là là les très
black pas un tgv à 20 centimètres des
voitures c'est scandaleux bravo je paye
qui est l'architecte de jeu encore une
fois mme el al et or à schruns n'a pas
le temps on n'a pas le temps on n'a pas
le temps pardon temporise un peu on
continue on n'a pas le temps excusez-moi
diva est franchement on n'y boulin et le
rush attention c'est parti
ah non non non non c'est un stop moi je
veux d'autres l'appui cement canaux
gratuits et nous consolent avec un
cadeau de temps c'était violent cette
scène canard boiteux j'adore mais c'est
addictif tout un hommage rendu à croix
rouge non au nom entre les trois c'est
dégueulasse c'est dégueulasse gagner des
gold hawk est ce qu'il faut faire
1 pour garder des pubs ah non mais stop
stop magic piano non ça n'intéresse pas
de jouer au piano sur mon smartphone
vraiment j'en sais ça fait gagner bien
pièce je voyais un auteur pub que vous
voulez ça ah non mesdames et sur la
portière avant je décède pas quoi à la
limite si vous la portière il me prend
avec lui mon aide mais je décède pas
chez désolé hommes et non mais retire
aux injustes qui se jette et que celui
casse de plus coller à plus de points
que tu vois là c'est un jeu que j'ai
jamais fait maintenant mais je voulais a
sauté sur notre feuille au sein de tence
intense et je suis tendu
franchement je préfèrerais me gifler
bieber déjà c'était beaucoup plus
original non tg tard oui on peut
regarder une pub rien d'une pub
scandaleux il ya cette chaise qui n'a
pas de faire du bruit elle m'énerve
voiture mais chiant c'est à cause de toi
chaise la up
non non je suis en colère comme ça un
petit canard est porté disparu
oui mais pourquoi à des failles et des
troncs d'arbres qui vont trop vite du
coup il se remet vite qu'il n'a point
qui t'a fait par un [ __ ] troncs
d'arbres sont vos cadres à ce qu'il a
fait part à trois pas fier de lui le
batteur de baseball
on va tenter de faire sens comme la mlg
flipper mais dans l'intro [ __ ] il est
cependant le seul carrément non mais
[ __ ] de texel longer le bout de voile
qu'on dirait qu'ils voulaient partir sur
le bout des doigts il quittait sa
bagnole mais ce que tu verras qu'il part
en montagne pour l'avion un truc mais je
ne prends pas mon bout de bois et en
plus on a plusieurs tu prends le mien
ont fait jeudi tra on tire haut d un
moment qu enfin pas il ajoute j'ai
inventé auquel il faut avions pas joué
non l'autre à pois
tamim fait peur s'inscrire ce train il a
écrasé alors que vous voulez à 2km
nouveaux records c'était là on a battu
le record ou s'enflamme là ça commence à
être un peu violent à temps mais le bec
en traversant joue au baseball quoi
calmement on a passé les 100 ans du chef
bords du touch est beau et le plus fort
symbole tout n'est
et il mourra dans un accident de taxi un
chaleureux [ __ ] mais c'est à coup sûr
vous espérez bordel tu es un daimyo
l'eau parce qu'il est heureux au nom non
d'écraser un chat ta part on arrête ans
il est grincheux vraiment up la nouvelle
carrosserie beaux gosses ou pas un fond
pire aux 80 mais non arrêtez de me
proposer des persos là oh non mais
comment il se colle à la voiture c'est
n'importe quoi
en fait on joue un sticker c'est le
secret de ce jeu c'est le stickers
panini bon au lit et voilà les gens
c'est à dire 30 cette petite vidéo sur
ces trois tubes ce soir ça vous a plu
si c'est le cas comme d'habitude
n'hésitez pas à traverser les routes
c'est pas ça que je dis d'habitude merci
à vous regarder on se tourne très vite
dans une nouvelle vidéo comme d'habitude
raider fou de joie de lire un jour parce
que vous le savez très bien alors
pourquoi le dire d'une embrouille moi
mais moi je même des petits coups pour
vous voilà comme ça
j'attends moi en pis
elle va
[Applaudissements]